a one Mardi Gras down in Lafayette
Louisiana I was at my brother's house
and it was like a street party you know
the whole everybody's out on the street
and my wife was leaning over a fence
talking to somebody and then guys from
next door came over and like bent over
her back while she was bending over and
put his hand on her stomach and like
started talking in her ear and then uh
bro
you just saw red huh yeah I ripped him
off I had a buddy of mine who fights he
started dropping this other guy's people
left and right dude I mean
dude 100 every shot that landed
everybody fell 100 he shot 100 from the
field that night
then I started punching this guy and
then he he had a lot more friends than
we did and uh my brother is not a
fighter so he didn't run he didn't run
out of the house to come fight but it
was just like people were fighting it
was a referee yeah and I ended up
getting my back up against a car because
they were jumping and I was like yeah
and I got hit with a bunch of uppercuts
it was crazy man Mardi Gras Mardi Gras
things Mardi Gras is fun though yeah
yeah